sí muy buenas días para ti tales como tú
has dicho son dos candidatos que
alcanzan mayor intención de votos de 16
candidatos a una sola mujer que se
estarían disputando la silla de
carondelet pero son los dos candidatos
que es físicamente andrés sarah 2 es un
economista de 35 años podría convertirse
inclusive en el presidente de más
jóvenes del ecuador formado en economía
de la universidad de michigan en los
eeuu al que no le es extraña la función
pública fue director también del banco
central del ecuador igual forma ministro
del talento humano y por un breve tiempo
ministro de cultura de igual forma es el
candidato apoyado por rafael correa que
se califica como latinoamericanista de
igual forma también guillermo olaso es
conocido como el eterno candidato ya que
es la tercera oportunidad que se lanza a
disputarse la silla de carondelet de
igual forma guillermo el lazo también se
le conoce como el super el ministro fue
el ministro de economía de expresidente
marwat en este país por el cual intenta
hacerse con una silla de carandolet por
una tercera ocasión ya que perdió
con el expresidente rafael correa y el
actual presidente lenin moreno la
intención presidencial así ajustado y
según las encuestas ningún candidato
lograría el umbral necesario para ganar
el domingo que margen tiene
bueno tal como tú lo indica todo parece
presagiar que habría una segunda vuelta
electoral el 11 de abril en este país la
normativa electoral establece que el 50%
más uno o sea mayoría absoluta más un
voto debería tener el mayor binomio de
en todo caso si esto no sucede el
próximo 11 de abril debería realizarse
una segunda vuelta electoral